with this heat wave going on the city is
reminding pet owners about a new
ordinance as hector mejia reports it
cracks down on people who leave animals
under the hot
summer sun to get the message across the
city of las vegas got together several
agencies along with
a couple of dogs that are famous on
instagram this year will be hippo the
black labs
first time under the hot las vegas sun
make sure she gets air conditioning we
have us
we actually have a fan and misters
outside murphy the golden doodle plus
this trio of
basset hounds are helping the local fire
department remind people
that it's never a good idea to leave
anyone outside under extreme heat
we experience one to two calls a day
sometimes even up to 50.
there's a new misdemeanor ordinance in
the books to prevent animal cruelty
chief luis molina is head of the city's
department of public safety
what's changing is that if the
temperatures are expected to seat 105
degrees
and the pet owners are required to
provide misters swamp coolers
air conditioning they cannot leave the
animal in many cases dogs
outside in the heat in addition to that
molina says if the national weather
service sent out a heat warning
animals cannot be tied outside they have
to be brought in
if you see an unattended pet inside of a
hot car
dial 9-1-1 do not try to break into that
car
another reminder that pets can dehydrate
quickly
don't take them for walks during the hot
parts of the day
it's important to know the symptoms of
overheating in pets
which include excessive panting and
difficulty breathing
increased heart and respiratory rate and
drooling and mild weakness stupor and
sometimes and worst case scenarios even
collapse
we'll be posting the specifics on the
changes to the city of las vegas
ordinance on our website
8newsnow.com reporting in downtown
hector mejia
8 news now